this is the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hashim azuz and today
I am joined by Karl Penhaul who is a
principal consultant for Austin Fraser
and we are in the very big we work in
Paddington very impressed yeah it's
pretty cool it's pretty big one I mean I
did am tweet recently where I said I'm
getting less and less unexcited to go to
we works because it's like same
furniture same vibe yeah just start to
not enjoy it as much I've lost the buzz
a bit but other than I've actually got a
bit of the buzz but for this one it's
huge yeah there are to be fair we worker
pretty good I guess partner of ours
we've got offices all over the world now
really who's we work pretty much in
every sort of country and state in
America I think if I'm right and said
and yeah this one this one's pretty cool
services uh sprite work quite well at
the moment that must be a very big bill
we can make well as you know we're
always like to start call how did you
enter the world of equipment mate it's a
really good question so I guess to give
a little bit of a background sort of
finished off college had no idea what I
wanted to do was a pretty avid cricketer
so moved to South Africa so how did you
get into quickly
I think cricket terrible so once again
really funny actually I used to be
football mad and I was walking to
football training once walked across a
cricket pitch and probably like one of
those films you'd see where a ball rolls
in and then blitzie threw it back and
was hurt and that was probably probably
ten or eleven years old
and then just yeah fell into it so
played cricket was fortunate enough to
sort of do that to a pretty high level
lived all around the world South Africa
it lives in India for a while Dubai I
spent time in yeah and then money in
cricket is not the best so it was
actually yeah that's the thing I guess
it's only as football as wasn't it's
like there's this fantasy of like you
want to be a professional make it a pro
base it's that top top top top yeah an
attempt
actually get to the point where it's
like I'm set yeah definitely definitely
I mean I was fortunate enough to play it
sort of quite a high standard but I mean
unless you're you know on the TV every
day and playing for England that's sort
of where you know that the big money is
but in compare in comparison to football
you know even the top foot below sort of
top cricketers will earn maybe 1% of
what a profiler yes really
you know nowhere near as high so was
playing cricket really enjoying it and
then I think now probably around like 21
22 one of my very close friends go
Ashley Blanchard was working frost and
Fraser had done a similar sort of
journey to me through cricket joining us
Tim Frazier and sort of went from
trainee to senior to principal within
about 18 months and we were walking
around the boundary one day and he drew
the boundary as she do cucumber
sandwiches but now walking around and we
just sort of got on to the discussion if
you know what I was up to cricket was
probably you know coming to an end I was
you know trying to earn as much money as
possible so it's actually working as a
scaffold err on the side as well respect
so and then he said well look we're I
work for this company Austin Fraser
we're about you know 40 40 people now
we're growing why don't you come in for
a chat and it kind of combined did
everything that I thought I wanted to do
really anyway I was always like what
what do you like doing I love speaking
to people I love you know I always sort
of had that you know ambition if you
know the hustle and bustle of London or
and on this job or something so yeah
went in and had a chat and I guess the
rest was history we're now joined Austin
Fraser September well it'd be five years
in September so just to make it crystal
clear you've had you go into recruitment
and you've said some phrases yeah last
five nearly five years yeah and that's
been in the recruitment business you
work for the only sales experience I
mean I was a barman for a little while
so I sold points but yeah yeah the only
recruitment or sales experience I've
ever had yeah I'm excited to and I'm
packing that journey I think that's
generally really impressive and amazing
that you've been part of the business
journey and beam
of one business for so long because you
know is like so many people end up with
recruitment for a year two years
sometimes lesson and they're moving and
they're moved again yeah so I guess
firstly like what how what was your
perception and recruitment then as
you're walking around the boundary what
was your perception I guess if I'm
completely honest if I think back five
years ago LinkedIn wasn't as you know
prominent then my activity on LinkedIn
wasn't so I guess my perception of
recruitment was what I knew from like
what my friend Ashley it was you know I
guess a sales orientated job and I guess
if you think about in the nicest
possible way it was like glorified you
know people traffickers you buy yeah you
know people want you know whether they
be developers or whatever industry and
that's what you do that was really my
perception I guess I didn't really ever
think you know the intricacies of it and
how it actually Ellis you I think the
way in which lost and Fraser sold it I
think that I actually you know bought
into Austin Fraser straight away because
I went in there and I sat down with a
group of six of us and if I'm thinking
about the same six they're five of them
are still with the business now which
speaks testament and they were all
people that were sort of similar
backgrounds you know come from a
sporting background we all had similar
you know interests so I'm all like
cricketer yes yeah a lot of us do play
cricket a lot of golfers you know you
have the notorious whim recruitment
either a state agent background and
people that use maybe so gym memberships
or whatever it was but I guess they just
sold it to me in terms of you know you
don't need to necessarily have any
experience we've got the tools and the
resources to give you everything you
need and I guess my driver to get into
recruit room as it was playing cricket
scaffolding was to earn money a you know
and they said we've got the tools to
make you earn over a hundred grand a
year you know and and you know well
you've been there for five years less
you let's just frame up a bit more fair
run listening so
what what have you all had what markets
do you recruit in cool so I guess that's
a little bit of a journey so when I
first started Austin Fraser we were
obviously a lot smaller but our model
but for people that don't know is where
IT specific recruitment can we have
vertical market consultants so
ultimately we have different teams so in
our business right now we have a Thames
Valley team our head office is in
Redding so we have a team that services
Oxford reading the sort of Bristol
Southwest area and we have the team that
I sit on the service London within my
London team we've got a sort of a
subsection one that does just contract
recruitment okay I'm one that just does
perm yeah and then once again within
that you have vertical market
consultants so for example I've got a
colleague that just does Python contract
in London I've got another colleague
that does Python yeah so python is for
those who don't know as well it's like a
programming language so basically
whatever skill set or technology or
coding language that's used we normally
have someone that just recruits for that
area I guess that's how we sort of grow
deep especially yeah we've grown our
specialists and not just within like a
technology stack as it were but then
within either contract or Perlas ARCA
and you've always been in contract
always contract I think probably like
most recruiters and maybe contract I've
done a couple of perm deals that sort of
you know happen along the way but very
much my I'd say my bread-and-butter
contract recruitment yeah so and then
within the niches that Austin froze
operating and did you did you star in a
different nice - we do now yes yeah so I
very fit when I very first started I did
Java which a back-end programming
language like the Java contract London I
did that you'd probably go on to a
minute I did I did very well to start
off with so a deal win a week and a half
of starting really having no sales
experience and you know saw I've smashed
here yeah I've completed recruitment
will go onto in a bit but then but then
blanked and didn't do a deal for seven
months but no started off doing Java
contracts probably after about eight or
nine months moved over to the Python
market okay which is once again another
back end
in language Python contract London I did
that for probably around two and a half
years I'm trying to think now yeah I
then actually moved over to Denver in
America Austin phrase who have now got
five soon to be six offices in America
yeah so I was fortunate enough to move
over to Denver live there for a year and
help set up the office there once again
still focused on the contract model that
the American sort of business has I've
moved back to the UK in May and I'm now
leading the JavaScript technology side
of our business but once again through
contrast okay cool thanks for that
that's perfect so let's sum what why I
always like to talk about obviously gave
us a bit of a flavour there but I always
like to uncover those first five months
because bloody hard working at 12 months
yeah I've had my own experience of that
so so went into the the the contract
piece right and obviously as you said
made a deal on the firth in the first
week and a half yeah yeah yeah yeah Oh
completely I mean if anyone ever tells
you there anything in there first I
would say probably six months of
recruitment they've done on purpose of
in there talking [ __ ] a lot of it is you
know right place right time luck in the
work and we've so it was a you know a
counterpart of mine to someone that did
Java perm London called a client they
needed a contract
I was walked through taking a job spec
you know thrown in at the deep end so
you know sometimes now it's like cool
well you know your manager would take it
throw another deep end so I guess you
know I had some touching points were
there then went out and recruited the
role found a candidate that having the
candidate was actually referred to me by
someone else I why don't you try this
guy and yeah went from there so it was
very much right place right time but
yeah you know I think I think it was a
week and four days from you know
starting to ring in the belt yep I am
you know I don't know many companies
they're probably do deal tunes or
something like that I remember spending
the whole of Friday not doing a single
bit of work and trying to think about
what my deal chain could be and to this
day I still can't remember
so say yeah it was a bit of an
interesting one but valuable a bit of
experience positive and I guess you know
what to follow so then seven months
after that back to back roughly yeah I
did try to have a little look before
before I before I came this evening but
yeah yeah roughly it was it was
definitely good you know five six seven
months with nothing yeah how'd you do
that
probably a few tantrums I think if you
were to speak to some of my colleagues
you know once again luckily enough
they're still working for the business
now there were definitely some tough
times yeah but I think what really
helped me was a colleague of mine Dan
filmer who is still with the business
now we started a month apart he's
getting married next month we're off to
that in Dublin we've had the sort of
really great relationship and I would
advise people if they're if they're
going down that journey of latching on
to the people and the colleagues that
you work with because those are the sort
of people that will get you through it
so dan dan was on a bit of a different
trajectory he sort of joined the
business and you know it was very
successful like I was at the beginning
but just sort of carried on and me and
Dan have had a similar journey where
when he was doing well I wasn't and
likewise he would drop off potentially a
little bit and I would do well in it so
what we've you know I've dealt with that
six or seven month period by you know
speaking to the people that were doing
well picking their brains on sort of
what stuff they were doing I mean I
gotta give a shout out Austin Fraser
were brilliant I think there's lots of
sales companies that you know two or
three months without a deal you know
you're out the door
you know we talk a lot about you know
skill and we'll do you have the skill to
something deal to do it I think when you
start as a trainee you know unless
you're you know I have the will yeah you
don't have the skill you know I think
that anyone that comes in like I said
and does something in their first six
months a lot of its luck but what I did
have is I had the will to learn I had a
good team around me we've got a
brilliant L&D function on certain
phrases that helped me and you know
slowly but surely you learn how did you
do for the rest couple of months and
to the sort of year mark yeah so at the
end of that hit my first holiday
incentive so I guess it was a bit of you
know learning over those six months I
also then moved market to Python which
was a little bit more of an established
market you know it was a bit warmer
there was a there was a few existing
clients and stuff we had but I think
that journey over the six months to
really you know identify what my drivers
were and find out how much I really
wanted it you know then took probably
over the next three or four months for
you know for contract recruiters I think
finished that first year may be running
around sort of 1,500 to 2 grand a week
GP but hit my first holiday incentive
which I think for me was what was huge
it was really really busy a big
confidence boost from these things yeah
yeah so just quickly before and we move
on mate so I love the fact that so
firstly what did you what did you get
out of so how did you approach pick on
other people's brains and stuff like
that obviously it's great that all
student raised and supporting these
things but like what was your intention
when you was trying to learn from these
other people do you get one me because I
think a lot of people when they're in
that environment it especially in the
South yes it's hard to be like yeah coal
lot I'm actually really struggling yeah
you know I mean it's a lot how did you
approach that because that is difficult
yeah and I think you know once again you
know just advice for anyone else out
there is I can only speak from
experience with Austin Fraser but I know
for a fact that you know everyone you
know within my team or other teams in
the business want to do exactly the same
thing we're all there for each other so
I don't think you know any point I was
ever made to feel silly or stupid or you
know I you know I'm a very proud person
you know coming from a sporting
background and stuff but I think you
know the biggest change in me through
recruitment was being able to I guess
suck that up a little bit and being like
you know what actually it's fine to say
you know I don't know what's going on or
it's fine to say I'm struggling you know
if you're having really [ __ ] days and
stuff take five or ten minutes out go
and chill out a little bit you know
refer back to your drivers why did you
get into the job initially and I guess
you know a big thing was once again you
know speaking to people and
understanding cool that we've been
through that we've done it there's no
shame at all in saying you know I've
blanked this month or I've done this as
long as you your will is there
then you know I don't think well once
again academic speak from Austin Fraser
but you know the wheels there there's
people in our business that have similar
things to me when they've blanked for
six months and they were maybe you know
more senior than I was at the time but
we've held on to them if you're asked to
choose their the behaviors are there and
your will to do better
you know then our companies so I think I
think it's just that light don't
underestimate that people around you
will be wouldn't tell ya did you know I
mean and I guess for you then like was
there anything else that you'd like
through those tough times you just you
mentioned interview time was dry your
driver yeah she said like those few
months also help this little tap-in to
light your drivers and these things like
how light talks to me a bit about that
cuz I think that's really interesting
because not everyone actually would do
that right yeah so what you're saying
there is think about why you're doing
what you're doing and these things like
how did you what was the process around
that because I think that's interesting
yeah I think I remember who it was that
said to me once was I think I talked
about a little bit earlier but
ultimately the reason you know I joined
lost in phrase it was to earn good money
and give myself and you know family
members and partners whatever is better
opportunities you know and I was always
told you know I went to university and I
did a levels and stuff but by all means
was I not brain of Britain but you know
I came out and I spoke to a lot of
people like Ashley my friend and
McCrimmon and said look we've got the
tools to you know you can earn over a
hundred grand a year here and for me
always remember it not necessarily that
you're gonna earn loads of money but the
reason why you want to earn that money
you know for me I've got very very close
family you know my aspirations to be
able to support you know whether it be
my sisters or my parents or whatever it
may be you know in the situation the
motor were me and my partner trying to
buy a house five years ago I had never
dreamed about being able to do that you
know fortunate enough to not be able to
go on nice holidays now and you know you
know have nice cars and stuff like that
for me that was really important and I
guess you don't really realize that
until you're down in the dumps sometimes
because someone said to me once if you
in any sales job if you look at your
basic salary you could go and do a very
easy job and earn exactly the same if
not probably more money you know when I
first started Austin Fraser the basic
salary was 18 grand you know
we've now improved our structure and
changed it a bit but actually if you
look at 18 grand when I started I could
do a lot that was so easier but
different jobs I know I mean and earn
more than that so actually call not
maybe where you want to be now but also
the work that you do now and someone
told me this and it's so true the work
you do now is basically effect in six
months time so if you do [ __ ] all now
you know it's not gonna affect six
months you know you're gonna be in the
same position so I always saw cool with
the work I'm doing you almost drive in
for something better you know that mean
and actually if I sit around a moat for
the next three months
well this three months is gonna be [ __ ]
and then the next three months as well
so it's kind of you know learning what
those drivers were but also listening to
other people's advice and being like you
know what actually I've got the tools
and the capability to you know and
really good money and enjoy it so you
know I'm really gonna try you know
mouthing that's that's really interested
in the fact that you really tapped into
my actually why you're doing it and the
people that you can benefit because also
you mentioned a few times that I've sure
driven by money and I'm sure when you've
interviewed four people for your team
and stuff like that that's what you
wanted to say but obviously it's okay
why do you want that money yeah that's
what's really gonna help them through it
yeah and especially when you're getting
rejected 50 times a day
yeah thing you're failing these things
so so that brings up too so so basically
those they end up being like the end of
the tunnel yeah your first year and so
then also you move to a different
slightly different vertical yeah Anu is
in for a lot too in the beat yeah right
yeah so so just give me a bit of context
so then did you sort of climb the ranks
is your life friend it's like what did
you over as you did you continually to
do well then did it go in the one
direction yeah yeah I guess yeah I was
really lucky actually so once I moved
over to that Python marker I'm trying to
think exactly when it was but probably
about nine ten months in moved over to
this Python market coincidentally we as
a business a very very hot on meetups
and events and we actually started
probably ten years ago just for just
after we as a business open set up a
meet up for Python in London which I
then took ownership of so I threw myself
then when taking on this market so you
know running events and meetups and
why'd you do that brand I know that's
sort of what we're talking about here
but you know that's why me and you get
along so well I think it's because I've
found that as a recruiter you your
product is the Canada you represent and
you know although I think sometimes
people like to think that the candidate
they represent is the best thing in the
world which it may be 99% of the time
that's not an exclusive Canada so
another recruiter can find that person
and sell it into one of your clients
yeah so I quite quickly realized I had
to do something to differentiate myself
from just the Canada or a CV I do
something in Austin Fraser moidhu
masterclasses where sort of principals
or seniors give you know some insight
into their business and I do want called
service led sales which talks about you
know having a CV isn't enough these days
there's so many recruiters around having
a CV isn't enough it's the service in
which you provide around that for client
and candidate the ultimately makes you I
guess indispensable you know I'd like to
really like to believe that the clients
that I work with you know and hopefully
some are listening now and not in a long
but that the service that I provide to
them as well as the candidates it is
really you know like a partnership as
opposed to a recruitment company and
that's that stemmed a lot from the
meetups that I attended and ran myself
you know we got to a point where
juggle the Django user group of London
was was probably the most successful
Django Focus meet up
I think definitely in London if not in
the whole of the UK and it still is now
so that really you know I guess probably
love the way that you approach that and
again just quickly like the dad just
come natural do you like that whole sort
of okay so this is understand bit more
about real criminal and it's very
saturated it's difficult because you
know I mean like that I wouldn't say
that's the normal perception or the
recruiter to get one means yeah where
did that come from I think a combination
of probably my journey through sport and
things having to stand out and
differentiate yourself you know playing
sport I went to you know just you know
the normal school down the road and a
lot of people I was playing cricket
against were private school kids and so
for me I had to sort of try and make now
so I think a bit of that but also I
guess the the historic stuff that we've
done Austen Fraser you know my my first
ever boss John set up this juggle meter
and it was it's always being I guess
ingrained in us Austin Fraser that you
know meet ups and differentiating
yourself whether that be through you
know podcast like today or content or
whatever it may be it is key
you know I refer back to it but there's
so many recruiters out there that could
ultimately go on a job board and find
your goal candidate and sell it into a
client potentially a lower rate or for
something different which mission so you
actually got to make yourself stand out
and even if they do present that same CV
your client says no I'm not going to use
anyone else because of x y&z okay Karl
get it
housing make more money so I think the
way it made me earn more money was I
once again like to feel that especially
on that Python market I became the go-to
recruiter okay you know that there's
definitely lots of people that you know
there's probably other Python recruiters
out there listening that would disagree
but I think I had such a good network of
candidates and also clients that you
know I think it probably got to a point
at the end of it where my BD almost
became minimal just purely because that
because you again more inbound business
yeah yeah lots of it was referrals it
was meetup driven it was repeat business
it was yeah you know word-of-mouth
it was all that sort of stuff that I was
a period of time do you think that oh
yeah something there's been around but
and then what was the period of time you
think that you really really start you
probably looks at your colleagues like
this is like really taking off now yeah
so I think say if we say if we go from
like day one of start in the Python
market I think for me to really get to
that point was probably a year maybe
between a year in eighteen months just
in how often when the events every three
months monthly quarterly
quarterly oh sorry yeah yeah every three
months but what I was doing is providing
content so I was doing content that led
up to the events and then I was doing a
newsletter which had all the speakers
involved in photos of me in there that
I'd attached to every single email I'd
send so I was although they were every
three months in quarterly I constantly
had touching points every single week
and snippets of the event that I'd share
so it was they were every three months
but they were almost instant they were
almost constant feeding and as soon as a
month and a half went by the last one
I'd then start speaking about the next
one yeah and we bought in a really great
marketing function and design team
everything in-house that were brilliant
at doing that you know I couldn't have
done it without those guys you know help
him provide content and how to market it
and stuff so okay before we move on I'm
just really interest in that because I
think there'll be a lot of people
listening and I talk about personal
branding and these things quite a lot on
see that ties into that and I'm just
trying to think people listening okay
quahog Elliott how does it make more
money you answer that I think that
that's great but just quickly them
before we move on some like real real
practical advice yeah if I'm thinking if
I'm listening right now I'm going right
actually yeah starting to meet up or and
then for my niche would actually be a
really good idea what some like really
practical advice to go from great idea
to like start you're not starting it
give me some practical advice and then
some learnings that you would do
different analogies to go back yeah I
think we had some really practical
advice for people out there thinking the
same is you need to research what is out
there at the moment okay when if I think
back to when I first started in Austin
Fraser did we were probably one of the
first recruitment companies to do
meetups a hell so that definitely helped
we saw big you know created our own
little niche however there is so many
companies there are so many clients
there are so many sole contributors as I
say drying out quickly so it's a button
that that definitely helps with at the
same time like don't think oh now I'm
too late to the pie yeah I was gonna say
there are so many people now whether
they be clients or sole contractors or
meetups already that needs support you
know there's lots of meetups that I know
of that really struggle through the
funding for example
I'm funding when I say funny it might be
fifty quid every month on pizzas yeah
you know because a lot of these meetups
are in a pub somewhere or they're in an
office space after work and actually if
you're out there thinking you know I
want to forge my way in something reach
out to the organisers and offer your
assistance in how yeah I think that that
would be the way if I was to do it now
that would be the way I would do it I
mean I've just launched a brand-new
meet-up called leaders in tech which is
something that Austin Fraser has sort of
forged over the last three years but
that was an area that we researched
heavily there was nothing like it around
specifically at CTOs vp's head of steam
value so there are meetups you can set
up on your own but just make sure you're
researching and if there's something you
can support and see if there's something
you could support to start off with ok
and then also then so two things how how
do you approach it so then it's not like
our colleges doing this then he earns
money or how does yeah bit like of cause
a recruit I'm gonna get sold to yes I'm
there so how how do you how do you
navigate through that yeah I've always
been really open and honest with anyone
and said you know if there was no real
benefit for me then I wouldn't be doing
it yeah so I don't think there's any
shame in hiding away from the fact that
if you're a recruiter and you're
involved in a meet-up maybe not
initially but you are there to gain some
value within your business so don't
first of all I don't think it should be
like oh no this isn't what it's better
be honest because everyone knows and
that's fine but also think about what
value you can give to a the people come
in be the people hosting it and see your
market and your network you know think
on those three points point score so
look I'm gonna gain something as a
recruiter because I'm gonna meet clients
are gonna meet Canada's but what am I
going to give back you know am I gonna
invest in some really cool speakers to
come that mic are the people that are
attending that meet up we're gonna walk
away from I think if everyone's really
transparent and says cool we'll look the
people are tending to get in value yeah
the clients office that we're hosting
that are getting access to loads of
developers that they wouldn't have
normally and me as a recruiter is then
I've never come up to a situation where
people are unhappy with that I think as
long as you're really transparent be
like honest and this is why I'm doing it
but also want to help as well and give
value back
you know that that would be how I we're
about and how I have got about very good
advice I think just to run off as well
my opinion is like recruiters are in
such a such a unique position to put
great people together I think now is
such a value I'd like it X group of
developers may not have never had access
to X person that they would love to hear
their opinion and perspective in so and
then the last thing before we move on
and what's like so a fun thing and call
mazing advice that what's like what's
being what should I go to structure of
an event to go I mean like what's worked
really well and we've got some really
good feedback again just super practical
yeah yeah so I guess he's find a really
cool venue normally with a really cool
company that's up and coming one of the
big companies yeah not good companies
often yeah so sometimes it may be
clients that we work with yeah it may
well be clients that we're trying to
work with it Seiler actually look what
we do is provide you with candidates but
also we run events and we can give you
access to this you know personally once
again don't be afraid of doing that it's
another value add let you get access to
our candidates but also you get access
to these really cool events that we host
yeah so try and find a cool venue
whether that be a company or a space try
and hook it on a really cool topic
there's lots of events out there at the
moment that are focused on you know just
thinking of maybe a front end one I'll
react you know react is your the most
popular framework probably at the moment
but actually find something that's
really interesting there's so many you
know interesting you know whether it be
markets like inshore tech there's loads
of insurance tech companies at the
moment for example yeah try and latch it
onto that so find a cool venue find a
cool topic branding and marketing is
huge on it you can't just expect to
throw an event together chuck it on
LinkedIn expect people to come you need
to get influencers involved in it and
they could be you know some of the key
developers within that network so when I
used to do it I had a group of 10 20 you
know some may be listening and I
appreciate all your help for the stuff
you did but they would always repost and
re share and invite people on their own
that's how you build a proper brand so
if I was to say three bits of advice you
know of how you're gonna do it that you
know that's what I'd say thank you man
no I really like that and again just
just to finish it off a thing then
surely cuz this
how I use the podcast when I was at hook
so it's then all of a sudden if you want
to be the X amount of companies you're
not talking about jobs you're talking
about an event that you yeah that's your
daily practical yeah yeah there's
there's loads of advantages to that and
yeah thanks for sharing that mate so I
guess cool so let's let's go into some a
bit more to your journey then so so then
you ended up working in that and Markham
sort of two and a half years yeah so
then did you did you end up managing
people or did you how long how long
would you just a sort of sole biller
four yeah so I guess I started off and
as you started off so day one started
off with the Python market probably
around four months went from a trainee
to a consultant yeah still sole
contributor consultant to senior that
probably took me about a year maybe a
little bit longer and you know at Austin
Fraser maybe similar to other companies
it's not just billing focused it's about
executive maturity so it's like what
you're doing behavior rise externally
internally so yeah probably four or five
months from trainee up to senior maybe a
year maybe a little bit longer and then
I chose the part at that point to go
down towards a principal consultant
which is still a sole contributor as
opposed to lead I think once again at my
at that time I was got home on a now I
was probably like 23 24 I was very still
money motivated I've got a lot of
satisfaction out of me ringing the bell
and doing deals and although I like
helping people I was very very focused
on what I wanted to do so I went down
good self-awareness man yeah I went down
the principal route I hit principle
pretty much well the quickest that you
could do it after so I hit senior three
months after and they have to wait three
months my hit principle and I guess as
we speak I'm still theoretically a
principal I did then probably maybe
seven eight months roughly as principal
moved to America I've now returned as a
principal but I'm starting on transition
now over to like a lead slash team lead
wicked McCool so let's
definitely gonna talk about your
experience in America and style yeah
let's let's quickly then what's clear
then for you to achieve that obviously
it's more than just Billings and
performances everything else which you
spoke about which is great but clearly
your performance must obviously I knew
gone in a positive way right yeah and I
think obviously I come from a
recruitment background but let's sort of
break down some advice and learnings
that you've had from taken as you said
your weekly GP to ever where that was to
wherever it was its highest point let's
talk a bit about that journey because I
think yeah yeah I mean so yes so I guess
let's just just set the tone so like
what what was sort of the the peak of
like way around these things then we can
Brett as a reverse engineer has to light
something what was the peak when I am on
as my we at the GPM school so I think
its highest it was roughly just under 15
grand aware and what does that does that
I guess they do yeah well I think it
depends on overseers contract concerns
we'll know depending on what your weekly
GP is you know translator yeah I had I
can't think now however many people
running and you know it built the built
the business or rung in the business
just under 15 grand a week cool so let's
break that down yet so like how lot what
were the key things that helps you get
there firstly like if to think about if
I'm if I'm on contract recruit list yeah
now and I'm 18 months two years in and
I'm at that they're still with this sort
of I don't know what's like give me some
context a lot was like someone's lot
doing pretty decent like if you're like
2 3 4 5 kg peers that is that pretty
decent I think that it's really it's
really difficult to answer that just
purely because different markets will
have different weekly pays you know I
think development has fairly good weekly
GPS you know you're looking at sort of
fairly high day rates for contractors
Google you may have network in support
or people like that that notoriously
maybe have a little bit lower
however yeah you know I think in terms
of where I was in the business when I
was at my peak I you know I was top
biller in the company I had the highest
weekly GP but there's definitely some
things across the way that got me there
outside of you know just doing deals it
was it was all the stuff that I spoke
about there and
to building that brand building that I
guess building that reputation you know
so I always got taught that whatever
your weekly GP is for example you would
always have in the contract market
notoriously around 10% finish every
month because sometimes you might have
three month contracts six months so when
I was running 15 grand or in and around
that a week I was having 1,500 finish
every month so I was having to do three
four five deals a month yeah just to
stay still yeah so at that point there's
only so much new business that you can
generate in a month so when I really
started to I guess kick on it was making
sure that the existing business that I
had was either really solid so
contractors where either you know in
very long contracts you know and
advising you know because 90 percent of
contract recruiters would agree with me
here you'll write someone a three-month
contract and almost always they'll get
extended yeah so for me it was about
educating the clients initially and
saying well cool why don't actually
because you've got this notice period
let's get a six-month contract initially
and if you start thinking about it that
way your business the longevity of it
then grows that way rather than you know
two months in a contractor's head gets
turned by hired a rate and you lose and
then you've got a refill and you kind of
just then plateau up and down
maybe when did you start soon okay
that's interesting so just just quickly
to make sure I understand you started
doing consulting on well actually
normally the people that I'd help me
find or whatever the contracts is coming
name the air typically you may want them
for three months but have you thought
about having them for six months
whatever right so then that helps you as
you said the peaks and troughs reduced
and then also it helped I guess from an
Avant
advantage for a contractor is that and
everyone's give a bit more stability
yeah they're interested in it so yeah
did you start then okay sends the
clients will actually be fought about
this and so that started to change yeah
I I think that they're the most
important thing for me and the most the
biggest thing I identify where my
business really took off was when I
stopped stop being a recruiter and I
started becoming a consultant yes ma'am
you know as we speak about when we're
messaging and stuff I'm in London now
our head office is in Redding
we've got satellite offices in London
however I'm in London three four days a
week
solely on site with clients that may be
clients I'm working with new clients
meeting candidates every single
candidate that I've ever worked with
there's one I haven't who's based in
this building that I haven't met yet for
lunch but every single candidate that's
ever worked me I've met for lunch okay
every single Canada I work people buy
from people if that candidates on site
he's not only a representation of me but
Austin Fraser you know I want him to
have a bit of hip or her have a bit of
ownership in like cool I want to do a
really good job because you know what I
really love Carl he's such a great guy
and I'm representing him that's exactly
the same as when I've speak to
candidates I'm an extension of a client
so if I give a candidate a really shitty
service but I'm representing you know
azuz Brandon you know it makes your
company look [ __ ] so I as soon as I
started understanding they're actually
people buy from people so it's really
important for me to get in front of
clients and candidates and also look
after your contractors because
ultimately your contractors are your
presence and you know there's no beating
around the bush they're the people that
only money yeah likewise so you know for
me it was really important to make sure
that the know you're so difficult you
know anyone in recruiting will know it's
difficult to do deals so actually when
you've done one god you want to hold on
to that one yeah you know anyone I've
had people that have contracted me for
years and I still once a month go and
meet them every single Monday I'll text
them some of those you guys think about
it some of those contracts is now
clients of mine you know contract to
right place in one of his first ever
roles he's now a client of mine you know
and actually that as soon as that
mentality for me changed of quick wins
quick wins what yeah I think I think
most people would cut especially doing a
deal in like two weeks like a did quick
wins you know and also call the work I
do now is gonna benefit me in six months
as I said I'm unstuck I was working with
candidates probably five years ago and I
maybe just placed them this year or I've
just started we're working with them
that's an extreme way to go but it but
it's happened I can think of a few
examples where it's taken three four
five years for me ever to place someone
or
or maybe work them as a manager so as
soon as you get that long-term vision I
think that will help you as well yeah
and then I guess so that obviously you
mentioned there about being a consultant
obviously clearly relationships doubling
down doubling down on actually having
having the right mindset long term ones
that these things anything else and
specific to the contract world do you
start to change or some really specific
habits that then you should really start
doing daily weekly they're really
starting to pay dividends over three
months six months twelve months yeah I
am I got into the habit and I still do
this now and anyone that works you know
within our team or anyone that you know
I hopefully I have the pleasure of
hiring in the future I'll always tell
them this that the contract market
specifically is very very candidate
driven so if you don't have candidates
in the time it takes you to go out and
find the Canada on a job that you've had
called in someone else will have filled
it I always looked at it like no matter
how hard I'm working there's always
someone out there that's working harder
than you
you know I many people in the office
will agree with me but I you know I'm a
bit like a bloodhound if I find
something I'll go after it yeah but I
always saw God if I'm being lazy there'd
be someone else that will fill it so I
always had three four five six
candidates that I'd work with before you
know I took references on them so it
would bolster their opportunity but also
for a client they'd be like wow it's not
just a CV it's a reference different day
rates depending on their ability I knew
where they were interviewing when they
were interviewing how what they liked
this that and the other so that when a
job got called in for me I think at one
point in terms of my CV to fill ratio
was almost one-to-one Berlin I think in
terms of it my my peak I say it was
probably around sort of three days from
job called in you know obviously there
are some jobs that take I remember
looking when I was doing you know quite
a few deals
it was almost when a job got called in I
would pledge it to my manager because I
would get commitment on it I would also
always try my best to get exclusivity
and I know that I've got three four five
candidates there and while I'm taking
the job description here his three CV so
the time to get CVS was five minutes
and that was part of why we double down
on your kind of network yeah I knew them
inside out yeah definitely definitely no
and also combining that with what you
know about your clients and that's where
this sort of you know what Austin Fraser
do is that meetings that consultancy you
don't you don't learn stuff like that
over the phone with people no matter how
many and I've worked with people that
have spent six seven hours on the phone
you know there is no way on earth that
they will get as much information buying
then meet look what me and you doing now
by looking in someone's eyes no way so
anyone out there meetings meetings
meetings that's key really yeah I like
it me okay cool so quickly then so
obviously reaching that I mean may
that's like big like that's amazing that
I'll see you you really go in that top
one five ten percent of obviously Austin
phrase a big company right yeah so I
guess now then from from what from what
you've seen actually wait just quickly
it so what i wanted to just aren't you
there was if i'm sure you've seen this
around you where i don't know you've
been talking about back then for the
last 5-10 minutes but what are the
typical things and that you think
prevent people from getting to that next
level would you go i mean that you've
seen around you that's probably quite
common yeah I think sometimes
complacency a little bit I think it's
very very easy and taking about oh you
know I'm by no means saying that all of
this came to me you know overnight and I
was all of a sudden managed to build up
a realized you know there are certain
times where you know you may and I've
done it before you have a client call in
you don't necessarily have that
exclusive candidate there but you've
worked with them before they like you
you like them so you think I'll actually
I'm gonna go home at five o'clock today
and I'll get working on it tomorrow
someone else will fill that job yeah you
know I always think about it and might
one of my bosses says to me said just
imagine if you had you going up against
you and I was like okay yeah you know
because I know that if I got a lead at
seven o'clock at night on a Thursday I
would chase that lead until twelve
o'clock at night.i because that's just a
sort of mentality so I always say you
know and I think that's I think that's
what the clients and the candidates want
you know our clients call me up and I
think clients want them to be like car
alert we're in the [ __ ] we need someone
they know that I will stay in the office
or we you know might go home now and
work
but they know that I will find them
someone yeah I think that's that sort of
relationship stuff that we were talking
about where you know I'm a I'm an arm of
our business or something and
complacency complacency
I think sometimes reaffirming what your
drivers are you know I've worked with
lots of people before where it's like
cool I want to buy a house and then they
buy a house and then they're like cool
yeah that's love that driver you know
I've worked with lots of people and you
know a guy that I work with once again
he was there on my first end he's still
there now he's a director now when I
started he wanted to get married and he
worked his nuts off and to afford his
wedding and he did and I remember him
saying to me after Oh God he said I'm
trying to I'm working out what my
drivers are now and the me it was so
good because I was like well would you
mean yeah and he was like it's fine to
be sometimes to be like actually I don't
know what my drivers are yeah and I
think advice to anyone it is gonna be
lots of light roads and winding roads
and stuff like that through recruitment
or any sales industry and that's
absolutely fine if sometimes fine you
know to be like Archie but that's not my
driver anymore it's this but I think
it's really important to sort of sit
down whether it be three months six
month yearly and reaffirm to yourself
what your driver is because that
ultimately is what gets me out of bed
every day buying a house with my partner
now is what gets me out of bed every day
that's my driver right now but once I
bought our house then we'll work out
what we need to do it may then be
getting married amb having kids but I
think it's really important so I would
say complacency and reaffirming what
your drivers are probably two of the
things that I've noticed that will stop
you going through wherever you are now -
and that could be running 15 Granary it
could be running 30 or 40 grand could be
billing a million quid I don't think it
differs you may be a training you're a
principal I think having a driver is
really really important okay man last
question before we talk about your
American experience which I'm keen to
talk about and because clearly to get to
have those achievements you must have
some organization and some structure in
your life
what did a typical car Penhale top billa
they look like good question I think
there's two two answers to that I think
when I was building what I was building
it was very very structured it had to be
it was very very much candidate focused
and once again you're gonna have people
that are contract billers here or perm
billers I still think he's exactly the
same candidates are king they rule
different you know they're your product
so it was almost always very very
candidate focused I got into a habit
very very early of having a really
organized database and that was
something that was sort of I guess
drummed into me by my current boss
Charles who was I if you for example
have a guy you know a great candidate
that you want to get out to people where
are you gonna send him and I I've got a
really good memory for if you say a
client now I'll remember who their CTO
is what his mobile number is sometimes
where he's work before us that's lovely
helpful in your contact but you can only
belong on that so much yeah I'm like
great I found this really nice skill
when I want to sell him in somewhere but
god I can't remember I've got a database
there and then makes it and then you're
also contacting people with relevant
information rather than just cold
calling and being like I've got this
person are they any good for you we
don't even higher in that market are
brilliant yeah do you know I mean I was
always making sure that the stuff that I
was doing was very relevant but in terms
of my day plan it was always very very
candidate focused I'm keeping your
database up-to-date from the beginning
because it's a pain in the ass to change
it you know some people use bullhorn
zombiu sales force whatever it may be
keeping that as as tidy as possible
I always put aside I do it do it more so
now time for client and candidate
meetings give me details in so like what
getting them what a o'clock yeah what we
do what we doing so then you block do
you block out your Thomas about eight to
ten I'm speaking to my existing
candidates it used to be I must admit
now net now it's very it's very
different because I'm now sort of
potentially looking after a bit more of
a team yeah my time is not solely mine
now yeah but when I was a sole
contributor
it was very much in the office anywhere
between 7:00 and 8:00 yeah probably the
morning was and you know the morning say
maybe firm you know what 8:30 until
11:30 12:00 was Canada focus it was
probably job boards it was adverting
kind of that existing ya know an
existing you know your existing
candidate so your rising is they're the
people that invested in the market so
for me it was always you know about
who's hiring where are you going what
were you up to you because as I said if
I had a client call in and they needed
John for example and the other
conversation in the morning then you're
laughing yeah yeah but also call him
every hour you know because if you're
giving people value and value add they
don't mind speaking to you it's when
recruiters call up candidates or clients
and speculatively sell them a job or
something and there's no value at all in
there that's when they'll get pissed off
with you but speaking to you know once
again I use John for example as know
I've got a call with this person in a
minute if they wanted you to go in
what's your time slots like what a great
experience it is for a contractor and a
client for you to say call well this guy
I know where he is now
you can come over and meet you in 10
minutes or by saying well I don't know I
spoke to him last Tuesday and let me see
if he's still available because 90% of
the people we deal with are not hire it
and not actual hirers they're normally
tech people or they're normally you know
people that jobs aren't recruitment if
that makes sense
so the quicker you can make the process
for them and the candidates the better
experience they're going to have the
better brand you're gonna create the
more repeat business are gonna have the
happier people so that was my mentality
I basically did all the legwork
throughout the day basically training
for the main event you know depends it
was between have some time to eat yeah
grab some lunch grab some notes probably
a lot of the same really really know it
was you know the stuff that I was doing
was not rocket science you know a lot of
the event stuff you know took up time
but you know outside of that it was
client meetings I would like to try
always allocate time to
development and he sort of try and build
new relationships or I did but I think
naturally that happened through the work
I was doing with my candidates it was
you know and some people have to have a
very sort of strict call this is my BD
hour but my mentality and I don't know
if you know I cut a client actually said
this to me once if in your business say
we've got you know 200 people asked him
phrase there across the world for
example if from 10 to 12 every day its
BD time how many other companies do you
think are doing 10 to a time and how
many how many that manager how many
[ __ ] times you think his phone is
ringing
because he knows 10 to 12 BD time so for
me I always thought actually it was a
little bit more of a you know if I speak
to a Canada and I'll find a lead for
example I see that someone's hiring I'm
gonna go down that rabbit hole where it
takes me and then I'll come back to the
candidate thing so I had a structure in
terms of it was very candidate focused
but I always made sure you know if I
wasn't doing enough BD and my point I
was looking low I would normally just
get back on the candidate stuff because
the candidates that I speak to you know
because I had such great relationships
with them it might well be working with
Canada and trying to find them jobs and
taking references because I've never all
very very rarely ever placed anyone that
I haven't taken a reference thought or
know from the Meetup and network so for
me taking references and then talking
about the meetups that I run naturally
migrated into BD and then I'll go and
meet with people and then it was it was
that sort of like so on and so forth
okay yeah thank you yeah it's a car why
did you go to America yeah really good
question so when I started Austin Fraser
I was very much wanting to be like an
individual contributor it was all about
me me me me probably about 18 months ago
trying to think yeah probably about no
longer than actually two years I started
to I wouldn't say you know properly
mentor but we had some sort of more you
know junior younger members to the team
that I sort of took under my wing a
little bit and I started to get as
probably most people you know
who are in maybe sort of my position
will started to get a little bit of a
feeling of I'll actually I'm maybe
getting a little bit more satisfaction
at seeing other people do well and it
stopped being all about me which if
anyone that knows me probably will come
as a bit of a surprise you know it
definitely stopped being all about me
you know I used to love I'll vividly
remember a colleague of mine who's once
again still with the business this was
probably three years ago Liam join
don't--if know it was his first deal but
I member sat down next to him coaching
him through her call him ringing the
bell and the satisfaction I got out of
that was with 10 times better than me
ever ringing the bell or hitting any
incentive that I ever did so at that
point I decided that I wanted to go down
a sort of like team lead type path and
at Austin Fraser where I was at the time
that wasn't really an option we had a
much smaller team we had a bit more of a
less defined path we have now very you
know we've overhauled our whole
progression path but I had hit principle
and there wasn't anything above that it
was either principle or team lead and
there wasn't the option within the
business to do a team lead and we now
have senior principal principal director
but there wasn't any of that so the only
opportunity that I saw was to jump
across across the pond and still with
Austin Fraser
and have a part of setting up a brand
new venture basically I'd seen a couple
of people who once again still work for
Austin Fraser who had worked in our UK
office have moved now and they James and
Alex actually set up the whole u.s.
branch we're now five offices in five
different states but they set it up so I
thought I saw them doing I thought
actually you know at the time at the
time that I decided to do it I was
single um and then I decided to do it
and before I left I got with my current
partner a difficult year apart but but
yet for me it was a challenge it wasn't
you know what I've wanted to put myself
out my comfort zone I wanted to learn
new things or
to see new things you know I'd always
traveled a lot playing cricket and you
know and Pete and Dell who are the
founders of Austin Fraser
fully supported me and what I wanted to
do and yeah it was an amazing experience
it was it was you know brilliant
brilliant year
okay so let's um unpack that a bit
because I think it's becoming obviously
really popular now for UK businesses to
open American branches the opportunities
seems to be great and these things right
so before before we finish may let's
sort of finish on on the sort of
American experience yeah these things
then we can sort of wrap up so I guess
firstly just give me some context so you
was obviously setting up something
pretty much from scratch in terms of the
niche and the vertical you were doing in
America yeah yeah so we was Denver this
thing yeah that's right yeah so
Colorado's estate and Denver is de is
the place here within it right up in the
in the Rocky Mountains so beautiful
place you know snows you know quite
frequently sunny all the time very
rarely rains lovely place but so we as a
business set up in Austin four years ago
and then after that we then set up you
know we've now got Denver we've got
Dallas we've got LA we've got San Diego
okay but Denver Denver had been set up
when I went over there there was four of
us okay I think so I wasn't you know one
of the first but there was Oliver who's
another English guy who had been bought
into the business from from another
world from an s3 type company to sort of
set it up and run it and then there was
I think there was three others so there
was 4 so plus me I was the fifth one we
were in a we work type building it was
six months old well I think probably six
months yeah literally from the start
came first thing on a nine yeah
if I'm a recruiter right now I'm in a
sim similar position that you was yeah
and there's an opportunity with my
business or there's an opportunity to
join another business progress my career
mhm
haven't been there a year now come back
what should I be talking about if I'm
looking to move my life as a recruit
America yeah the rhetoric isn't gonna
tell me about you know I mean yeah it's
gonna be a lot of thing yeah yeah the
fees and all this right so what yeah
what things do people need to think
about if they're considered movement I
think you know once again I'll harp on
about you need to think about your
driver again you know fit for me I think
if I'm if I'm looking back honestly I
think my driver was probably wrong I
wanted to progress but I think I thought
actually I probably could have done what
I wanted to do Austin Fraser in the UK
my driver was wrong I saw the bright
lights and I saw you know the big city
as it were a lot of people probably
experienced yeah yeah yeah you know and
I think you know being really open and
honest I sent my driver was probably
wrong however you once again you know
really great time do as much research as
possible every single state in the u.s.
is completely different you know we you
know I did very limited business outside
of Denver but I did work with some
companies and place people in New York
and even just as much as like tax laws
and stuff like that and that's that and
that is with contracts and perm they are
so different that do your research you
know implicitly I visited Denver for
five days before I moved there when
there for five days the company sent me
there which was great in hindsight
should have spent a lot more time there
you know I should have gone there for a
lot longer you know I don't know where
the companies you know people that are
looking to move will facilitate that but
I would definitely very sir
do you research go there for longer it's
tough it's really tough especially if
you'll go into a sort of startup sized
business you know as I mentioned earlier
I'm a huge family man my family's you
know but you know pretty much everything
so when you have a really [ __ ] day at
work and you go home to you put that
next to an empty apartment and there's
nine hour time difference so no one's on
whatsapp yeah and you can't speak to any
one firm we probably you know me and my
partner spoke properly once a week
because of the time there and you like
please anyone I'm being you take that
into mind because that was really tough
you know I went to deal with that I
really struggled if I'm honest you know
obviously you know me and you have been
speaking for a long time you know I'm
quite a confident guy
crowd person so you know for me being in
such a poor so you know shitty place
some times where you know because
startups are hard you know anyone that
joining recruitment whether you're you
know on your start of your journey or
the companies you know cool yes in
America there are bigger fees purely
just because salads actually true
salaries are higher okay so you know
salaries are higher therefore the
percentages or sorry the fees that you
will get will be higher yeah in terms of
percentages not not really you know I
think you know we work a very similar
percentage in America and Germany and
the UK so I wouldn't say percentage but
they're they do tend to behind because
the salary people yeah so you know on
average you'll look at anywhere around
sort of 100k salary and in the UK you
may be looking at something closer to
maybe 60 yeah in Germany it's maybe 80 I
wouldn't necessarily say that they're
higher sorry higher they're higher fees
but only because the salaries are - not
necessarily someone's gonna pay you
fifty sixty years okay so it really may
fully respect that definitely I think I
definitely find that really hard light
to written don't take into consideration
that if you haven't got a social network
over there if you've got a girlfriend
family blah blah blah like that that's
no joke yeah you got to be comfortable
with that
yeah as you've already said the only
potential is definitely higher because
of the fees yeah I guess then the next
thing then that I'm interested in is
what were the sort of clear different
nuances that you picked up on quite
early to go through that so if you're
then now didn't move obviously American
clients and obviously businesses in
Denver Amish yeah and as you said some
some outside of Denver what were the
different nuances in terms of coal
picking up the phone I'm a recruiter for
Austin Fraser what are the things that
you picked up on what they were probably
quite different yeah I think I think
straightaway obviously a lot of people
will be a lot older English accent you
know comes across really well and stuff
don't get me wrong people identify with
an English accent but I wouldn't
necessarily say our god it's you know
the the golden key that lets you yeah I
remember when I moved there I've got
friends in recruitment they said oh god
you know when you're you know making
calls it's gonna be easy
because you know you've got that English
accent it's definitely not the case
anyone that's thinking that it
definitely is then
what I really struggled with that the
coming you know not to tell sort of too
much will go into too much detail but
the model of recruitment over in America
is I found very very different so
permanent recruitments is actually the
same you you know charge a percentage on
the person to be where in the UK and
people will relate notoriously you'll
have a candidate and they will either
want contract work or permanent work
yeah in our industry and that's
technology in America candidates don't
care which makes it really really
difficult because I went over there to
sort of take a bit more of a lead on our
account management function which was
ultimately contract so for me it was
very very different it was actually I
haven't got where I did so much
candidate work and I had really gone
candidates I then almost no longer it
was like I went over there and people
took my product away so it was like I
was trying to sell something that I
didn't have a little bit and also the
model the we as Austin Fraser and also I
believe lots of companies adopt is in
the UK you have what we call 360 repeat
of consultants over there you have 180
so you'll have someone that does the BD
and the account management and then
you'll have someone that does the
resourcing so I found that really really
difficult to as I spoke earlier you know
I combined the candidates and the
clients I was doing a lot more of the
sort of account management and then I
bought in a couple of people into the
team that sort of sat with me and did
the resourcing I just found a real
disconnect between you know if I took a
job description for example and this is
no you know tissue sets the people work
that they then because it's gone from
cold take them Joseph it's then cold
communicating that to the candidates
yeah I'm called taken and then
communicating to Tina then communicated
to the market yeah so it was just it's
just that disconnect for me it was
something that I guess in you know I had
a hat wasn't really aware of probably I
think for me it was you know the biggest
thing that I'll take away from you know
the America thing was you know I
probably needed to do more research into
it yeah you know also at Austin Fraser I
was the third person that had ever done
it
you know we had Alex and James that went
and set up the whole American function
than me so you know the rest of the
people were from the map yeah everyone
else was American hired we've now sent
over or with half of us they sent over
we ship them all three or four more and
a couple of people from Germany have now
moved out there so it's now much more
you know I guess common thing yeah yeah
definitely so I guess you know in terms
of those sort of nuances is you know if
you're a contract recruiter make sure
you do your research into sort of what
model you as a business adopt and how
that works
one the other thing that I found quite
different is the time in which it took
for deals to be done
I found it and this may well just fear
yeah I found it a lot slower people just
a bit more chill well every single
company from my understanding as soon as
they get any sort of money in the UK
they invest in tech in America the first
thing they hire is a HR person or talent
acquisition so it once again then adds
another layer and that's not a problem
but just for me
the company I work with the companies
that I work with in the UK a lot of it
was sometimes you know direct manager
contact it was a contract model that I
was used to so it was quick and then you
add in when I moved over there a
different model and then now we're
liaison through three or four different
funnels and sometimes portals to upload
TVs that was something that really
shocked me that actually and once again
I think it comes down to the research
that I did and also maybe as a company
the research that we did search to where
we were Wow yeah it was good fun it was
a challenge for sure I think it it made
me grow up you know in terms of you know
I'm 27 right now but in terms of when I
moved there you know what 25 25 25 26 it
maybe grow up a huge amount from like a
personal point of view and then also
understand myself but my business a lot
more I guess it moving over there and
made me realize not that I took what I
did here for granted but I maybe didn't
realize to value
I hope that I add two candidates and
clients but also how much I guess I
absolutely love doing what I did so you
know for me
the learns I take away from their huge
and obviously don't get hey you say no
yeah obviously that was yeah it was
definitely tough but I mean you know not
to sort of turn it into two sake but you
know me made it work and we're now in
the process of buying a house so you
know it was obviously you know what's
meant to be is meant to be also right so
being back in the UK yeah what you said
ten weeks yeah roughly I'm trying to
think now about ten weeks nearly three
months maybe and as we as we finished
them cuz I think I think just be good to
get your insight so are you managing
anyone right now or not so I so my role
is still a principal consultant we've
just bought on a go-to team Emily who
I'm acting as Ally consultant so we've
got quite a I think a really good
progression path Austin Fraser where as
opposed to going straight from you know
an individual contributor to to not
we've got a couple of sort of steps
between that which basically sort of go
from now that eighty percent of my time
is mine and twenty percent is dedicated
to another person on ice and the other
time she spent with my manager so it
gives me a bit of a flavour of
leadership
it gives ya loving it really loving it I
guess it allows me to do what I want to
do where I can still have control of my
own business but it's also teaching me a
lot of lessons about communication and
you know I think when you've been an
individual contributor and I guess you
know your own business so well you start
to assume sometimes that other people
know how to do things as well and Emily
for example who's just joined we've just
launched a graduate scheme austin fraser
and emily has come through that so she's
a she's a graduate so she has no you
know she actually did work in a state
agency for a brief time but in terms of
I guess for her she was like you know
this is her first recruitment job so for
me it's actually taking a step back and
being like okay cool it's another
challenge Whitner you know I think I've
it's probably said a few times that's
what I relish now yeah it isn't just
going up and ringing the bell and doing
my own deals it's something new so I I'm
excited it's a next chapter for me so
last thing may yes just before
we're excited on what's going on mm-hmm
and then you I think one thing for our
your career like you've been other than
what I feel that mindset has been like
quite key to Uriah viously sporting
background always having to compete
trying to stand out moving places in the
world and these things must have helped
with that but I guess what's been like
have you always had this sort of I've
always been quite sure of yourself or
when terms of the mindset piece how have
you cultivate that because it seems like
you really got to a good place and
obviously is continued to your mindset
has continued to have really success in
the UK when to Devlin was like Jesus
crisis okay yeah look at the mirror here
and be like yeah yeah I mean so like I
guess what's what's been your journey
with mindset and how important has that
been to you a huge amount yeah a huge
amount I think anyone that knows me sort
of from within work maybe you're getting
a flavor of it now but more importantly
sort of family members and stuff like
that is you know that mindset is really
important to me through that sporting
background and stuff positivity I get I
get called the peacock at the office you
know walk around you know quite quite
loud quite a positive person make myself
you know known but I guess for me that's
what I need to do to sort of promote and
create my positivity and my sort of you
know yeah that that mindset there you
know everything's alright and everything
that's gonna be good and everything's
can either yeah proactively try and
cause I definitely proactively try to
change it I think you know one thing
that I have done all the time throughout
like promotion targets is as I said
earlier it isn't just billing why's that
you get promoted us and Fraser it's sort
of executive maturity and stuff like
that and after I sort of reached a
certain point and was going through sort
of more senior promotions you know we
start to look at a little bit more about
how you're influencing other people and
how your perception is perceived across
the office and you know and some of the
things I think if anyone doesn't do this
360 reviews a really really vital and
that sort of getting feedback from a
number of different areas of the
business and something that was noticed
some times was that potentially when it
was good with me it was great and when
it was bad it was really bad
so identified that quite quickly and
sort of proactively now try and sort of
think cool how am I being perceived and
how am I having that positive mindset
and mentality
it is tough sometimes you know but I
think you know a lot of it comes from
that sporting background rulings like
that and also just you know being aware
of it and the drivers thing as well you
know you love the drive yeah I think if
in fact your mindset is you know
drifting off then maybe you know what
people get bored of it but maybe then
your drivers aren't right and maybe
they're not the same anymore maybe
you're not actually driving towards what
you think you were and that's when
you've got to take a bit of
self-reflection and be like cool where
am I now
what am i doing I think that
automatically just maybe pushes the
reset button on your mindset and okay
mate
well before we finish what's good so
what's going on your word then that
you're excited about so if you go any
events coming up or what what's going on
what's on the agenda yeah so there's a
couple of things I guess to sort of keep
an eye out for I mean Austin Fraser is a
business where you know we grow in as
ever as I said we've now got five
offices across the u.s. four in Germany
we are I think hopefully trying to move
towards a point where we've got a more
permanent office in London and that will
allow us to our guests dip into a newer
talent pool and grow our team which will
be amazing and hopefully I'll have a big
part to play in that events wise as I
mentioned earlier we as a business have
just launched leaders in tech London
which we had our first event about six
weeks ago it's purely focused on sort of
VP's CTOs head of x' just purely an
event you know that people can come to
who are of that sort of high c-suite
level and really get some value from
there you know peers moan about the
industry maybe more so than they can't
do in other meetups you know I love that
event also you know I was part of sort
of making it happen in Denver we now run
it in a number of places in Germany
we hired out a riverboat for the last
event and did a three-hour riverboat
cruise up and down the Thames we've you
know it's a little bit more than just
your you meet up with pizzas and beer
which is what I like about it yeah so
we've got another one of those coming up
in October
and yeah I guess those are two things to
grow for me and the team and also sort
of some more good events and stuff
really wicked man
so look question always like to ask if
coal could communicate to every single
recruiter out there they'd take on an
advice could be a phrase word the
sentence what what comes to mind
probably a couple meetings meetings
meetings whether that be candidate or
client I think you know face time is
invaluable with people so if you're
setting up a business if you're new to
recruitment get yourself out there and I
guess following that candidates are king
as I mentioned before candidates at your
product and I think your candidates but
also your clients hopefully will see the
value in you staying close to people and
being you know ultimately when they need
you either candidate or client you know
a really valuable ultimately member of
their team so yeah meetings meeting
meetings and then candidates and kinking
cars been a pleasure man she's very
share